let's go to the Clipper Clipper game you
lose this one there were all kind of
questions all kinds of statements being
made by players and by coaches about
here you know it's a it's going to take
time we're trying to get on the same
page we need James to be James you know
all this if you actually looked at that
game you saw their problems in a
nutshell they didn't make their runs
they took James out the game you go back
and look when they because they were
down double digits when they took James
out the game that's when they made their
run when Russell was playing the
primarily at the point that was the
first issue cuz James and Russ can't
play together secondly their lack of
size like yeah when zubot gets gets in
trouble yeah and and zubach he don't fit
with those other four guys you know
because the court is the court is so
stagnant so they can't play James and
Russ together they but I think they
traded all their sides away uh to
Philadelphia so man it's going to be uh
it's going to be interesting they've
been outscored by 70 uh in the five
games when James Harden has been on the
floor here's tyloo post
game um I thought going small was able
to switch you know switch a lot um take
away a lot of the triggers offensively
and then um going small just you know um
if ji is going to you know blister the
picking rolls you know get a small short
roll and making plays which we were able
to do and um to get back in the game and
so um that was encouraging to see and
then you know down a stretch what H us
to just you know him you know posting up
jic you know be able to score or make
plays I had to post um really hurt us so
um you know I was encouraged by some
things I saw tonight you know winning
the uh The Possession battle only having
11 turnovers you know we did a good job
taking care of the basketball um only
they only had six offensive rebounds you
know so doing a good job with that as
well you know and so they had some
things go their way you know Aaron Gord
makes the half court shot you know just
just big plays they made that um that um
kind of helped propel them to get the
win you know and so and I didn't think
you know tonight we I thought we were
doing a good job of driving the
basketball getting to the paint getting
to the basket and uh we didn't get the
same
calls how do you valuate James cuz had
21 points through three quarters he
looked to me at least the most
comfortable he been so far but then only
takes one shot in the fourth or scools
in fourth how do you sort of evaluate P
night I mean I don't really care about
it I mean shots you good just about how
the offense is going and um like I said
PG had it going and so he was able to
make the short roll pass
kind of get guys involved or James in
picking roll they were blitzing or he
was getting downhill making the right
pass and right play and so um you know
that was good to see like that's like
you say that's the most comfortable he's
been since he's been here and um this is
something to grow off grow grow off of
so um very encouraging you know
disappoint we couldn't get the win but I
saw some good
things yeah what are the positive Shack
you take away that if you're if you're
tyo and you know you heard Reggie in the
in the broadcast he said he said you
won't get a real good read on this team
until close to to the allstar break when
you see how things come together so what
do you take away that's positive if
you're tyo well his only mistake tonight
you know you talked about you know
switching everything you have a big
Joker Is Not Your Average big because
even though you do all this pick and
roll and you know you get him in the
disadvantage what you going to do on the
other end what you going to do on the
other end so you know with the small
ball didn't work like he said you know
Joker just posted up he either took him
one onone or he made plays I don't
really see a lot of POS I don't I mean
they they got back in the game you know
what I what I never liked about the
Clippers is they they wait till late to
come back and they try to Hero ball you
know Paul with the step back there like
that that's not how you win a
championship that's not how you get
better I would have lik to you know seen
them today you know because they played
hard they played hard James play I like
to see them today win by 20 so we can
say okay this works this works di SPS
but it's you know it's not really it's
not really much to read on especially
when you lose six in
Chuck made a great point a lot of those
guys can't play together in combinations
and they can't go small against a guy
that could score on the other end
Minnesota and I know reg's Point like
when you go to a new team you have a
bunch of new well well James is actually
the only new piece not shouldn't take 30
games but the problem the problem I
disagree with Reggie on is it's not the
players uh it's the players it's not the
time like James and Russ they're not
going to change they both need the ball
to be effective same thing with PG and
and Kawai so it they're all terrific
players but the one thing about
basketball you got to find a way to help
your team James and Russ they need the
ball to be effective they're not going
to change now um they need to play a lot
faster and I do think they need to trade
because you can't go out there with one
big guy because you got to go against
Joker you got to go against Anthony
Anthony Davis if you're going to if
you're going to be the best team just in
your own building you know you can't you
could because the Lakers got a big team
also don't forget Christian Wood and you
got the other kid who they just got came
up with from New Orleans uh I forget his
name right off the bat but you can't
have one big guy it would it would help
to get Mason plumbley in there for sure
is he he is out yes for for the clips
well you know there a saying the same
things that make you laugh make you cry
and he he said it in an upsh
what makes them laugh and and and ju
joval is they can't guard us when we're
small team's going to have difficulty
when they're playing well but when
you're small what makes you cry is he
said well then we couldn't like Shaq
said we can't guard him inside so in the
key moments of when you need a basket
they're able to get it easily where
you're working for it so this to me is
not about I heard you say about the
players to me it's about now he's done a
great job to this point but it's about
Tyron Lou he has to create an offense to
develop where all of these guys can
coexist that is what he's going to have
to do over these 20 games that Reggie's
talking about create an offense that
plays faster that small ball can rebound
or Andor if you get a trade that would
be the best scenario but you you have to
create that and now this is why coaches
get paid this is his job meantime the
Nuggets do what uh what championship
teams do uh game on line down the
stretch outscore him by 10 win the game
at home stay unbeaten on their floor